this is a production of cornell
university
i'm joanne labay i'm the vegetable crops
curator
at pgru in geneva new york where the
plant genetic resources unit
and my name is zach stancil and i am the
industrial hemp germplasm curator
although i have a great passion for
vegetable germplasm
um so we're really excited to show you
some of our field increases
this year
we're regenerating a number of annual
and biennial crops and we're really
excited to show you around so
although the primary emphasis of this
work is seed regeneration
to replenish our seed lots for
distribution this work also entails
characterization
and just general
germplasm and genetic diversity
conservation
so welcome
all right so as zach mentioned we have
biennial and annual crops onions are
biennial in the first year they produce
bulbs
and then we have to dig up the bulbs put
them in the barn over the winter and
plant them
the next year
to produce seed so first i'll show you
the first year onions they're here
we have 20 different
types or accessions we call them of
onion that we're regenerating this year
and the plots are laid out on these
plastic strips
and we try to keep a population size of
50 to 100 plants per population so that
we can get the random mating and keep
the diversity so i just wanted to show
you our bees
we rent bees every year
and they're back here we're not going to
get too close because they're active
because it's a warm out
but when we do the pollinations
each accession or each population is
isolated in a nylon mesh cage
and these bees somebody comes in early
in the morning while still cool out and
they transfer these boxes of bees
into the cage
and leave them in there for a few weeks
and all they really need is water and
they feed off the nectar of the flowers
and pollinate
i wanted to show you our second year
ions as i said
these are biennial
so what was planted this is 2020 allium
is onion and plot number 108 and this is
an accession that originated in portugal
what was planted are the bulbs and you
can see the bulbs are kind of
sticking out the soil here
and these will grow the plant and they
will flower
and before they flower
a cage will be put around them so that
they can have the bees put in and be
pollinated but we'll let them grow up a
little bit
before we put the cage over it
so here we have a cabbage increase cage
so this species is brassica ulracia
the dog of the plant world i should
point out it's a species that contains
broccoli cabbage cauliflower kale
brussels sprouts
uh chinese kale etc
these cabbages are kind of unique in
that they have a biennial life cycle so
these seeds were actually started last
year um
2020
grown out one year vegetatively
dug up and stored over winter
basically in a protected but outdoor
environment in upstate new york so they
got quite a bit of chilling hours during
that time so we moved them back out to
the field
and
transplanted them and they're just now
starting to to flower
so
um
many of the materials that we have out
here are not great cabbages they're
they're not uh something you'd be
thrilled to pick up at the grocery store
however that's kind of the it's that's a
feature not a bug um
these represent very genetically and
geographically diverse materials
that you know while they maybe aren't
the highest in horticultural value they
represent some sort of local adaptation
or potential disease or
abiotic stress resistance
so from a plant breeding perspective
it's incredibly valuable to maintain
this these diverse brassica resources
regarding the uniformity you'll notice
that unlike a inbred line or an f1
hybrid population
the plants that we keep in these cages
are
not very uniform and that's actually
uh uh
the the kind of the main point is to
preserve this population level genetic
diversity
um this lack of uniformity is actually
kind of a sign that there is some sort
of segregation occurring
in these populations and so we try to
keep a large enough sample size 50 to
100 plants
minimum to maintain that
especially since
oleraceae is an outcrossing species
having a larger stamp
population size is really essential to
maintain that diversity long term these
plots are our tomato regenerations
tomato is our most popular crop that we
can serve and we have about six thousand
different accessions of tomato
it's our most economically valuable crop
also
cultivated tomato is self fertilizing so
this is the only crop that we regenerate
that we don't use honeybees we don't use
cages
so they're planted in these rows and we
don't need as large population sizes
because they are self-fertilizing we
just need enough plants to get a lot of
seeds so
we do 24 plants per accession for tomato
and we're doing 50 accessions this year
and you see the wooden poles that are in
the plants will be trellised
when they get big so that
the plants are upright and that helps
protect them from things like disease
and it keeps the plots from growing into
each other so we can
make sure we have the identity
of the fruit when we harvest it
celery is another crop that we
conserve
it's also biennial so it gets treated
like the onions this is our first year
celery here
you can see the small young plants and
over here
is a second year salary so
they've been in storage all winter and
they were planted
they have a kind of a big
root on them
so we brought you to one of our seed
processing areas so we this is some of
the equipment we use to
thrash and clean our seeds before
they're packaged for long-term storage
in a
minus 18
freezer one
critical element of maintaining all of
these collections
there's a total of approximately 12 000
unique sessions spanning several hundred
taxa
so it's really vital that we regenerate
those materials periodically
um
if you know we do
a hundred
sessions a year then that's
120 years to
flip over the entire population or the
entire collection
so it's really important that we develop
new collaborations going forth
please feel free to contact joanna or i
if you have the capacity or willingness
to help us with those we'd love to have
those conversations with you
so we have
three primary
core groups of stakeholders that utilize
national plant germ plasm system
collection so
a primary user is plant breeders who
like i mentioned before
you know will find a sessions that are
locally adapted or have unique origins
or are valuable
in some regard for their breeding
programs
people conducting very basic plant
science research will will often request
our entire collection to screen it to
for example uh
conduct association mapping for a
certain gene
and then there's a lot of educational
value in these collections as well so
certain higher institutions will
use these materials i actually pulled
some of the brassica collection to show
a domestication timeline presentation at
cornell which is a lot of fun
so your biggest limitation is your
imagination when you have this much
genetic diversity
giving you a full tour would probably
take the the whole uh
the whole video session today we didn't
include uh the asparagus collection
which i'm working on regenerating um
we also keep many leafy brassicas
the radish collection is kept here
we have the buckwheat collection as well
and i'm
and yeah thank you julian the winter
squash collection is kept here as well
if you are a plant breeder or someone
doing research or
higher education and you're interested
in obtaining seed or germplasm from the
national plant germplasm system we have
a nice database a web portal online
called grim global
you go there create an account and you
can order
seed
we ship seed all around the world
and if there is any
information about the accession the
passport data
that will be in that database and you
can find it on green global if there's
any images same thing you'll see it
there
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu